hi I'm Nick Gillespie with reason TV and
today we're talking with reason senior
editor Damon root he's just back from
the oral arguments at the Supreme Court
for King V Burwell which is a case that
might invalidate the subsidies given to
Obamacare policies through federal
exchanges as opposed ones run by the
states Damon thanks for joining thank
you what is your sense of things where
is this at a very close case the liberal
bloc came out swinging in favor of the
administration against the legal
challengers Justin Justice Kagan said
look you know we do not read laws this
narrowly we read we look at the whole
broad context we look at the purposes
and of course that's what the White
House you know wants the court to
conclude Scalia & Lido they came out
very strong and favored legal challenge
against the government's arguments
Justice Scalia at one point said that
the government's position amounted to
gobbledygook I'm not sure if that's the
first time that's been heard at the
Supreme Court but it was notable so what
about the other three votes that are up
for grabs and where what could you read
where the justices were on that so Chief
Justice Roberts who of course cast the
deciding vote for Obama care in 2012 he
basically didn't say anything yes one
question he played a game of poker
didn't show his hand whatsoever so he
was impossible to read basically Justice
Kennedy was the most interesting one and
he said some things that suggested he
might vote in favor of the government's
position but what he said was the
government's textualist argument there
there there reading of the text is
probably wrong or he seemed to suggest
that however the challengers argument of
the text would make Obamacare
unconstitutionally coercive and that
would violate federalism so if the court
is confronted with a choice between a
reading of a statute that would render
it unconstitutional and one that
wouldn't there's this thing called the
doctrine of constitutional avoidance and
Kennedy brought that up and said well
maybe we should invoke that so that
would be the sort of ironic twist of he
thinks the government is wrong but it
would be even worse to vote against them
so vote in the governments favor so
here's a question Roberts of course
basically rewrote Obamacare he changed
definitions in the law when he you know
wrote the majority or the opinion and
upholding its constitution its
constitutional nature is there any
reason to believe that the justices
wouldn't do that here because you know
talk about the exact phrase that is
really under review here that the phrase
is established by the state what the law
says is that if people who purchase
health insurance from minutes from an
exchange established by the state they
can qualify for these tax credits and
the government's argument is is that
will that phrase established by the
state what it's a term of art and what
it actually means is established by the
state or by the federal government
acting in the place of the state and the
challengers say no the text means what
it says these words are very clear their
unambiguous and so I think the
textualist argument is strong for the
challengers but there's these other
legal principles that come into play and
one of them is this idea of ambiguity if
both sides maybe have an argument and if
maybe the broader purposes of the law
are served by the government's argument
that renders it ambiguous and therefore
the court should defer to the federal
agency in this case the IRS and uphold
the law so the the textualist argument
is not the only thing that could come
into play I agree that the text seems
pretty clear but that some of these
justices could bring up these other
ideas and rule for the government what
is what is your sense of if you had to
give odds why would you say that you
know King V Burwell rules against
Obamacare or maintains it as is I think
based on just what was said in the
arguments today like I said it's very
close I could it Kennedy seem to be
leaning a little more towards the
government side but I think that that's
I'm not sure I would want to give odds
on that I don't go too far out on the
limb but he seemed to be more on the
government side and that would be five
votes right there and then Roberts could
make it 6-3 or could make could could
add another one to the to that side
making 63 but it could be 54 for the
government with Kennedy crafting this
federalist constitutional avoidance
argument and then the Liberals basically
just joining him in the outcome but
coming up with you know they would
decide with the administration now
there's another case thats related to
this the hall big case talk a little bit
about that and it does that the will
this case render that one moot one way
or the other it probably will render it
moot they're basically the same legal
question there they've come out of two
different Federal Circuit's this the
king is out of the Fourth Circuit
he'll bags under the DC Circuit how big
is on hold right now the administration
lost in the first round at the DC
Circuit but that Court is going to hear
it again with a full panel and that's
scheduled for a few months down the line
and I think if the administration wins
here then that's that settles that there
if the administration loses that settles
it because it's the same legal issue
when will the Supreme Court release its
verdict on ruling on this traditionally
case like this it's the last week of
june the court goes right up to the end
of june and then goes on summer recess
unlike many of us and so we can expect
at the end of june alright well we'll
leave it there thank you daman root for
talking to reason TV thank you we've
been talking with Damon rude about King
V Burwell the big Obamacare case that
was heard today oral arguments were
heard today in front of the Supreme
Court for reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie
you